American Idol alum Pia Toscano is  engaged and she tells ET it's all thanks  to Jennifer Lopez you just got engaged  didn't you I did oh what's that like  it's it's crazy I mean I was so shocked  I met my fiancee through Jennifer we met  on the promo tour almost two years ago  so Jennifer introduced the two of you I  feel like all good things come from  Jennifer from American Idol to my future  husband so the show is everything she  officiate at your wedding  choreographer Jimmy ro Smith is the  lucky man who popped the question he's  also one of J Lo's backup dancers  Pia is one of her backup singers  Jennifer has been very good to me from  American Idol to this show she's been a  great mentor in my life and a great  inspiration and I can't wait so you guys  see the show it's gonna be beyond I  learned everything from her just her  Drive her determination how she the  second we gets a rehearsal she's there  and she's there till the very end  you